don't you [ __ ] make me cry oh
don't you effing make me cry
um
i turned 10 years old on the first day
of principal photography
of harriet this spy
so it's really neat to have a diary
because
you could just like write down
everything in it and no one will ever
know
we are so excited michelle because you
are the new host of meet mary murder
which is the true crime docu series on
toby okay
is it just me or is tia's behavior
looking very shady
what is the one thing that you want fans
to know before they tune in like is this
for those people who are obsessed with
all the true crime podcasts oh yes yes
meet mary murder is something i am
extremely proud of because
yes i am an executive producer i host i
narrated it we filmed it during the
covid and basically what i want people
to know is that we are honoring
the memories and lives of the people
lost
and i would
absolutely love people to be watching it
on to be because
i myself am an extreme
true crime fan
really
she said this person over there is her
brother
riddle me this everyone why on earth is
tia young pretending to cops that tim
lee is her brother but michelle you've
been the star of so many wildly popular
and beloved projects throughout your
career and we want to give your fans
some little flashback favorites with a
little rapid fire rerun
shake it up take a sit and wish for what
you like most in the woods
[Music]
can you believe that this year marked
the 25th anniversary of harriet the spy
what do you remember about that movie
when was the last time you talked to
rosie o'donnell like what first comes to
your mind michelle
don't you make me cry oh
don't you effing make me cry
um
i turned 10 years old on the first day
of principal photography
of harriet the spy
rosie was
my biggest supporter
there was a lot required of me i'm
extremely grateful for the experience
what i'm more grateful for is people
when i do look at social media which is
challenging
uh
them coming coming in with
you inspired my life you made me become
a writer
all of those just
beautiful things you know
um but yeah i turned
10 years old on the first day of
principalography which was 1995
and it came out in 1996 i believe
and next week i'll be 36.
so that's wild i just really uh
was so grateful
um i auditioned i think like
30 plus times
and i'll leave you with that on harriet
is uh
i still have the striped t-shirt that i
auditioned with in a memory box
it's supposed to be
what's it supposed to be what sad but
true you can do it when the camera's off
we'll work it out it's okay
have you talked to rosie recently we did
connect on instagram which i don't
really love to shout that out but um it
was sort of like
posey i'll got you
you got me
she protected me so much so i i have
via like some sort of messaging
have i mentioned i'm antiquated
but
via some sort of messaging just to be
like
i love you and it's so kind of crazy to
me because i understand that like people
don't apparently own a calendar but i
held her first baby
parker
on set
on
harriet and i'm like
what the f balls
cause he now like grown at af is that
what the kids say these days
she still thinks i'm little miss nobody
just your sister
boy is she in for a surprise buffy fans
will always know and love you as dawn
summers we love dawn summers if you
could go back and change anything about
your experience on that show or your
character's story line what would you
choose
i wish i stole more things from the
magic shop
actually i just i was texting with sarah
the other day and i was like oh man
i should have taken a whole bunch of
stuff
and
she was like you don't leave your house
which is arguably accurate
via the kovid
um but
she's like
and um what i what i love from that
experience is
you know i've known sarah for
we got 30 years something to that effect
yeah just shy um and i rubbed her belly
at her baby shower when miss charlotte
was
in there
um
and
now she's like she
like should practically be in college
right now i don't know
i love that you can measure your career
in co-stars babies
essentially and then seth green and i
measure it in how many cats we're going
to adopt
that's the way you want to play it
that's how we'll play it
no i'm not afraid of you anymore huh
you should be why what are you going to
do it's not what i'm going to do sweetie
it's who i'm going to do it with you of
course got to talk about georgina sparks
one of the most
iconic
combative personalities on tv
um we got to see a little bit from
georgina in the new gossip girl reboot
and meet her son milo what was your
reaction when you found out what she's
been up to and could we see you on that
show well what's so wild about that is
it was actually like friends of mine
that were watching the reboot
and then like sent me um what are they
called screenshots
of like
me photoshopped into
a lot of different photos you were with
like uh the ruler of north korea ed
sheeran like random i'll take ed sheeran
i'll take it sharon all day because i do
believe he's actually a huge muffy fan
so take ed sheeran and his like wait
what's the body song
that was terrible and now i'm never
gonna live this down i'm in love with
the shape of you
yes yes
oh god but i was like
huh
that's
me
but
look
you're like and there's my son georgina
is actually my favorite character that
i've played because she's such an evil
[ __ ] that um it was fun
would you ever play her again on this
new gossip girl reboot
i'll give you my canned answer for you
okay are you ready yeah i coined this
and because i am a writer are you ready
all right wait where's the okay the
camera is straight up okay ready
i'll never tell
you always didn't know how to leave them
wanting more
[Music]